controles como este son comunes en los
puertos del sur de la península
porque son lugares privilegiados para el
tráfico de drogas
hace unas semanas en el puerto de
salerno tres contenedores atrajeron la
atención de las autoridades vienen
desidia
y el origen de estos contenedores ha
despertado nuestras sospechas dentro
encontramos motores industriales dentro
había engranajes enormes completamente
cubiertos de aceite y así fue imposible
descubrir los narcóticos hubieran sido
invisibles en caso de un control normal
metodología de control estándar de
los agentes de la guardia de finanzas de
nápoles decidieron entonces desmantelar
los y ahora todavía les esperan muchas
sorpresas
84 millones de pastillas de anfetamina
algo nunca antes visto casi 15 toneladas
de estupefacientes es la mayor
incautación de drogas sintéticas jamás
realizada a nivel mundial
el comandante toma dirige una de las
brigadas que participaron en la
operación la droga incautada es captada
con una anfetamina derivada de una
antigua droga psicotrópica
que aumenta el estado de alerta y la
resistencia al cansancio estas cápsulas
son anfetaminas mezcladas con un cóctel
de otras sustancias paracetamol
lidocaína benadryl y estimulantes como
la cafeína hipótesis investigativa
nuestra hipótesis es que después del
primer confinamiento tras la primera ola
del coronavirus el mercado de la droga
se desbloqueó y los traficantes sacaron
este gran cargamento de drogas y kathy
bodis o sustancia estupefaciente
en un primer comunicado oficial las
autoridades italianas presentaron estas
anfetaminas como producidas en síria por
el autodenominado grupo estado islámico
y en las redes sociales el jefe del
gobierno italiano giuseppe conte habló
de una droga destinada a financiar a esa
organización
esta hipótesis no convence a algunos de
los expertos en el caso como danielle
rangers y especialista de oriente medio
durante 15 años por el momento si díaz
un país dividido en diferentes zonas el
régimen del presidente bashar al-assad
controla esa zona de la costa y por lo
tanto también el puerto de latakia del
que partió el barco por otro lado el
grupo de estado islámico está aquí en el
desierto del centro del país para llegar
a ese puerto ese grupo habría tenido que
cruzar zonas inaccesibles controladas
por los puestos de control del régimen
es un viaje muy complicado no hay forma
de que pudieran haberlo hecho para
daniele este tráfico sería más bien obra
de las milicias sirias apoyadas por el
régimen de al asad cercano a hezbollah
en el marco de una alianza con la
camorra la mafia napolitana que
transfiere diminich sabemos que hay un
conjunto de milicias paramilitares que
controlan el tráfico de drogas el estado
que debería controlar por el contrario
se está haciendo el de la vista gorda y
creo que había un trato entre esos
contrabandistas de captaron y la camorra
uno era el cargador y la camorra debía
recibir la camorra por el lado que vive
bajo esta marcha era un envío por un
valor estimado de mil millones de euros
para el fiscal de nápoles no estaba
destinado al mercado italiano
destinado según nuestra información las
drogas estaban destinadas a mercados no
europeos no occidentales es más probable
que sean países de tradición islámica
donde este tipo de sustancias es muy
buscada y consumida fuertemente leyes
cada está fuertemente ámbito
una sustancia ilegal a través de la cual
la camorra podría diversificar su
tráfico aprovechando la popularidad de
esta droga en los países de medio
oriente particularmente en arabia
saudita
la anfetamina como en el caso de las
anfetaminas como de todas las sustancias
psicoactivas está aumentando la difusión
y los mercados de destino
campeón oporto en las drogas fueron
traídas aquí para su descripción de
instrucción
las pastillas fueron incineradas
pero la investigación sobre las
ramificaciones criminales
internacionales de este tráfico
está lejos de haber terminado